I can finally talk about my new business
so the past couple of months have been
dropping some hints on the youtube
channel talking about this new business
that I've been involved with and it's
taking up more and more of my time and I
haven't been able to drop the name or
drop the kind of business because the
papers weren't signed and wasn't
official yet but now it is I signed
everything on Friday last week and it's
the business that I got two already been
invested with for the past couple years
it's Toronto dance salsa and I might be
filming from Jonathan salsa headquarters
right now wearing the t-shirt it's a
dancing company it's the largest salsa
dancing company definitely in Canada
maybe in North America and I've been
involved since almost the beginning and
what happened was the owner the founder
just wanted to move on to something else
and wanted to put her trust in the
business and somebody who cared just as
deeply about it as she did and that was
Mason's been involved for so long and so
I'm super excited it's taking up an
insane amount of time I've just
recruited on a new operating manager to
basically run the business for me
because I can't be involved in every
single decision I have my own business
my own YouTube channel and lots of other
things on the go I've been taking over
all the instructors we've got eight to
ten instructors depending on the season
and 40 to 50 volunteer helpers I've had
to meet with and I've got to get to know
better and I've had to talk about
changes that they want to make taking
over this new studio which is inside
empress walk which is a mall here in
that in Toronto and city got some plans
to spruce it up and make it look nicer
and so tons of stuff on the go how it
impacts my schedule is mondays now or
basically all about Toronto's and salsa
the operation manager comes over and we
grind it out for the day and then he
goes off in Fitch's to work for the week
and then throughout the week I am
popping in on the school we have socials
twice a week Denson soldiers of the
school and I make a point of once a week
trying to come to one of the salsa
classes or one of
boxes of you tomorrow salsa and kind of
mentor and guide one of the instructors
so i might go monday one week and then
tuesday the next week wednesday the next
week to try to give some feedback mentor
train diet instructors on how to get
better how I got into this business was
an interesting story when I was in
university I wanted to get into dancing
I wanted to pick it up and my girlfriend
at the time and I went borrow dancing
and she hated it so we dropped it and
closed at that same time I was just in
the process of selling my first business
my biotech startup and I broke up with
my girlfriend at the time I just sold my
business looking for something to do I
said hey why don't I go dancing again
and instead of going borrow my wind
salsa and this is where I think a lot of
people make mistake and when they're
looking for a business opportunity they
look just for something that they have
some skills in but not necessarily
something that they're passionate and
excited about and so when I went to my
first salsa class if I looked at it just
as a business opportunity I know I've
told this story to some of you before
but it would have made sense on paper
you know I'm too tall to be a salsa
dancer I take big steps oh it's harder
for me I don't speak the language and
interrupt with Spanish you know the
music was foreign to me all of these
things were against me but the thing
that helped me was that I just loved it
I went to a class I loved it I loved the
challenge i love the social aspect to
love the people and i've actually got
more involved with the company started
investing in it i now am the owner of it
and so here i am having to run two
companies at the same time and so I'm
just super excited lots to share i'm
excited i can get it off my chest and
share that with you guys if you have any
thoughts or questions one here's some
support and love you know give a little
congratulatory comment I feel it I
really appreciate that if you want in
the in the comments below and also if
you have any questions for me about this
business if you see a parallel in what
you're trying to do and I might be able
to help you or hey even if you have any
idea
for me I love the seat in the comments
below so thank you guys for watching
more updates to come soon my teacher is
a reflection of my life right the things
that I'm working on the business that
I'm involved in so you can expect to see
a little bit more Toronto dance salsa
stuff here as well as I'm either feeling
from location I might have some stories
to share our special guests on haven't
worked it all out yet it's coming soon
I'm just super excited thank you guys so
much for watching get to believe and
i'll see you soon